great thank you so much for shave it's a
pleasure to be here
apologize for the voice but
unfortunately I'm only speaking for a
little bit then we'll turn it over to
Saul who will show you some things I
wanted to talk today about some of our
plans and what we're working on around
really trying to help a rate computation
be efficient and more unified so this is
part of Kwan site labs we have a group
of people who are trying to be who are
effectively getting money from industry
and government through grants to form a
PI data core team so we can actually
keep maintaining the software we all
love now numpy many of you know was
created to merge to array objects there
was at the time there was the industry
was splitting we had numeric here and we
had a number right here turn it on yeah
that's probably good idea are we on now
there we go oh that's better I want the
yellows loud so you didn't miss anything
if you didn't hear the first part
actually
so numpy and and numeric and memory
existed and a lot of people are using
them sy Pi was built on numeric and then
in some other libraries are starting to
emerge from memory that was really
disheartening because there was such a
nascent young community and everyone was
14 in their different silos like we like
to do and I wanted to create an
ecosystem so I had 2005-2006 spent a lot
of time bringing them together borrowing
from the codebase of numeric bringing
the ideas of memory constructing dump I
built something that was great very
large community effort now lots of
people joined in wasn't just my effort
780 people are not contributing to numpy
670 to scifi over the 12 15 years these
have been existing now an enormous
ecosystem has lived up and grown around
these projects was fantastic so we
accomplished our goal create foundation
that would allow an ecosystem to evolve
and grow
now I've just changed out the top layer
there right we've got these new members
of our ecosystem the tensor flows the PI
torch is the chain there's M X net at
first they seem like they're just simple
contributors for ecosystem but actually
if you look at them they're actually
reforming the ecosystem they're
rebuilding they've all got their no
definition of an array we've got a huge
explosion of these frameworks now
there's not just one there's many even
though they're consolidated and we can
we've given talks previously about these
different and their relationship to each
other
but more than just new array machine
learning frameworks there's now array
objects everywhere Boreum and koopa and
tensorflow and x10 sir das or das ii
actually uses them pi torch MX net all
of these have their own array object
they've basically rewritten a lot of the
arrays that were there so we have a
divided community again which can be a
little frustrating for some of the spent
a bunch of the early time with no idea
how I was gonna make it to combine them
okay that's going to look at it
the problem with divided community is
not the explosion of ideas was fantastic
the problems that we're starting to see
now like I just saw another one torched
if EQ came out right which effectively
provides scifi OD int side by OD Oh Dody
pack has exactly the same function
called OD int and now they've got a
differential equation solver but it
works on PI torch so you can see we're
just gonna rewrite the world again on
top of an I write one and then
potentially look after the same thing
and we're gonna have enormous silos
again of libraries and only work with
one array or not okay we're a diverse
communities nobody look at it it's an
opportunity its opportunity to take
these wonderful things are being done
and and see if we can't do something to
help them combine so let's go back to
what we did with numpy we didn't just
write a new array object we actually did
a couple other things and so let's go
back to those things and see if we can
learn from them I don't think we're
gonna be able to write another array
object that unifies everything I don't
think that's that's sort of off the
table at this point
but I think we can look at some of the
other things we did and see if we can
amplify those to provide
cross-disciplinary and cross-platform
organization the buffer protocol pep
three one eight if you haven't read this
and not surprised most people don't it's
pretty low level stuff but if you look
at it it's it's why I'm a Python core
developer might anybody in the Python
core knows me because I contributed to
this pup buffer protocol and actually
wrote some things to try to unify the
way any object in Python talked about
its memory now that so okay that some we
did then to try to unify objects has
create this way to talk about DITA
together
the other thing we did was construct
this new dunder array interface in
Python landed under methods are a way we
talk about protocols we have dunder
ITER's we have done their necks we have
dunder ways maybe there's something we
can do here to actually define an array
protocols that people could use to talk
about arrays in the common way so that
these are two additional efforts let's
think about this
or visit those so a Quonset we've
revisited these and have come up with
kind of two projects they're basically
doing the equivalent of these in the
larger context the equivalent of the
buffer protocol is we're calling it X n
D it's a set of libraries that
effectively make any language able to
talk about data any kind of data so any
language can talk to you basically get a
pointer to data and a description of
that data and then hand it over to
across language boundaries and be able
to have a dispatch on functions that
work on that data type so it's
effectively a generalization of the
buffer protocol Thunder ray interface
earlier a couple of months ago and
really it's only this is a new new
project X and he's been going on from a
couple of years actually dunder you
array this you were right concept is
very very new it's but we've recognized
an opportunity to formalize and
generalize there a protocol for Python
and so the downstream projects could
define could depend on an interface and
not on specifics of a particular project
and then we can have back into this
protocol that's kind of the goal so when
we look at this let's see how we might
you know well talk breeze about xnd and
then briefly about kind of where x rays
headed and then saul who's my colleague
at kwan site is going to talk about
where we're headed with it and how we're
trying to get there so numpy if you look
at it at its core and it's there's a lot
of contributors to numpy but it's
surprising how few of those contributors
actually know see anymore and understand
how numpy is actually built and it's
built from these three basic objects
addy type object which the description
of what an array is the data type
instance it's really inherits from
numeric Spire a desk er one of the
innovations of numpy was to make that a
Python object basically but it's
basically a Python 1.0 kind of object
every instance of addy type is an
instance of a single class and not
plugged into the Python to approach to
instance two classes which all inherit
from meta types so there's a way to
actually fix this I think that actually
is consistent with Python 2 and Python 3
the next piece that's important is you
math mostly most of you know numpy
because of all the math you can do with
numpy nobody really cares about your
data structure if they can do something
with it right and so it's because of all
this math functionality and there's the
foundations is a map over scalars a
scalar kernel so you take a scalar
kurtal like an adorable
fly or outside and you apply that over
every element of an array with
particulars
now that was what numpy had to begin
with and it came from numeric the Shah
later in about 2009 2010 they added what
was called a generalized u funk now this
now enables the kernels to be more than
just a scalar that could be a
matrix-matrix multiply they can be any
function they got any signature that
actually opens the door for most of most
of numpy all of its math and functions
like argh sort and hard math to actually
be generalized you funks it isn't today
it's kind of the scattered version of
here's some you math functions here's
some other generic functions they could
all be the same and then n the array is
that pointer it's got the pointer to the
data and a few other information just to
be a general a container of an MD type
so X and E takes those three concepts
make C libraries for each of them and
that allows you interfaces different
languages so the three concepts in XMD
are live MD types which is the D type
generalization and it's generalizes to
categorical types to missing value data
types to all kinds of data that's not
available in numpy today variable-length
arrays variable linked pointers so
that's live MD types then you have live
geo math which is a generalized g-funk
dispatch mechanism if you have a pointer
that's defined a certain way is
described by Lichtman d types you can
then build a stack of functions that
work on that data and even register them
at lab to your math and that's in C
there's a sea foundation for that so any
language could easily just put that out
first to it go F sharp C Scala currently
we have language bindings for Python a
ruby why python a ruby well because we
know python we're gonna push the Python
first and then Ruby because somebody
showed up and said hey I want to make
the Ruby bindings okay so we're very
open to Java bindings anything else
f-sharp go you name it so that's X MD
discuss real strings got real
variable-length arrays categorical types
it's not numpy these are Caesar
developer libraries it's not a user
array you know friendly library but
pandas and ask and and x-ray could all
use X and D to get better functionality
better type system all right so we
integrate with num bus you can generate
you fungus from Python code and have
them work on your complicated data
structure to fine with X in D
but there's a talk about ura so again
instead of developer library's missing
features but it's used meant meant for
we hope within the year to have other
users use it to build interesting
features and we're gonna use it as well
with ura it's kind of like Apache arrow
I sometimes get the question of is this
arrow arrow is an example of what you
can do when you define a cross language
container XMD is a mechanism to define
all kinds of cross language containers
it's a way to describe any cross
language obtainer so it's a
generalization effectively other what
another way is simply to think about it
is panas is to arrow as numpy is to xnd
Padma's uses numpy arrow could use x
india doesn't today but it could their
apps are will in the future all right so
now we're get to the universal array the
universal array or unified array depends
on we haven't decided which we're gonna
call it yet exactly it's ura we ought to
pick it's kind of solving the problem
that I think exists of having many array
objects and not a common way to talk
about those objects I think it's kind of
similar to the Python bites string
problem in Python 2 and I say that
because people wrote libraries in Python
2 they use strings when they met bytes
because there was no way to tell the
difference and those became very
difficult to tell the difference we have
the same problem today people use
strided pointers because that's what
numpy is when they just want a logical
array and so then the libraries on top
have this dependency they don't need to
have so there's an opportunity to
actually prove that create an array
protocol or a interface that libraries
on top use then can be back to end by
lots of different array objects so
that's the goal so to get to reach that
goal we have to think about what is an
array or a tensor some of the
fundamental concepts and this comes from
numpy basically you look at you look at
numpy plus plus I guess numpy plus
things we ought to think ought to be
there so what's it what's the
fundamental constant for an array it's
got a shape I think it's the name tuple
so there's a name for the each dimension
I think for each dimension people really
like the index they like labels like an
index mapping from their label space to
these integers from 0 to n minus 1 that
gives you kind of the pandas
capabilities a function that takes up to
10 and then the key element is this it's
a function that takes a tuple of indices
and returns another array
we're gonna call that the size function
actually in honor of Lamar Mullen here
I'll talk about in a second so this is
that this is what defines an array is
that
that mapping between integers my index
and the object I'm talking about there's
other important concepts you'll want
things like a memory type you need this
MD types concept but then brought into
Python as a real type object that is you
know mapping to memory types slicing
sub-selection bin array from asking data
functions for calculation functions for
creation then you need a whole bunch of
API on top really to make this work you
gotta have the API that satisfies the
use cases people have so we've done
analysis of an umpire's API you can
actually see there's 545 functions and
umpire's api that aren't just method
aren't just labels and names
it's 545 different functions when you
import numpy numpy dot something there's
also 71 methods and they group into
these different categories emits a
computer transformation those are kind
of all generalized you math functions
creation reading reporting outputting
the next in sub setting these are the
things that have to be basically built
on top of we can't have an array
interface that has 626 616 methods like
it's too big numbers API is way too big
and a lot of these methods are really
combinations of a lower subclass so how
we're gonna define what that lower
subclass is so kind of earlier in the
day I think it was saw was that you
actually saw was actually quite a quite
a maven he's kind of quite a connector
goes out and connects with lots of
people and he introduced himself and met
Leonor Mullin and she's here actually
you'd wanna stand up Lenora waved
everybody Leonor I was super impressed
to meet Leonor because I've been a fan
of APL for a long time I've always
recognized numpy is really a grandchild
of our great current child perhaps of
APL it turns out Leonor worked with Ken
Iverson on APL way back in the day right
and she's amazing cuz she looks like
she's 30 or something so but she's been
doing this for a long time in fact she
took her work and actually formalized it
and made what's called a mathematics in
a race that shows how arbitrary array
based calculations based on again this
formalism of the SCI function can be
consistently defined
simplified than formalized and then
optionally implemented on arbitrary
hardware so she came with this
mathematical construct we thought okay
this is really actually close to some of
what we're trying to search for which is
a foundation for numpy kind of numpy api
on top
but richer or a concrete foundation we
can trust and so the paper is there
she's here you can talk with her
I recommend it there's a lot of
information there now she's new to the
Python ecosystem
so that's but she's willingness she's
eager and she's really able to help us
so the goal is brazenly to develop a new
array oka system initially for Python
with an abstract interface and a
concrete interface based index in D that
allows us much reuse to the existing
ecosystem as possible so we're
effectively talking about rewriting the
world but we're not gonna be right the
world we're gonna wreak reconnect the
world reconnect the site by foundations
that we built over 20 years but make
them possible for them to call an API
that can be backed by multiple things
we're gonna do some surgery and
interject this array interface API allow
multiple implementations of the array
and what this will give us is actually
the ability to have sparse arrays
immediately don't have just depend on
just oh it's got to be a stranded
pointer it can be sparse it can be
lazily evaluated it could be defined on
the fly Hardware backed it can be lots
of different things allow are allowed
pushed onto an FPGA pushed down to a GPU
and then like important for this to
succeed is libraries like SCI pilot
knowledge side PI optimized have to be
built to work with this array interface
so it's this is a big goal and it's not
something's gonna happen in a month or
two months this is like a three year
goal you know I think we'll be able to
progress in eighteen months maybe by a
night of next summer we'll have a kind
of a foundation of things working we're
talking about it now because we do have
something's working and we're looking
for help we're looking for people want
to collaborate we're looking for
resources looking for funding it's
definitely some weekend we can work on
we've got quite a team so in addition to
Lenore and Saul we've got PR ooh PR o
actually was the guy who helped me build
site by the first time right he wrote F
to PI he was very instrumental in
bringing the linear algebra tools to
sci-fi he's already worked on x india
build x Indy tool so we had Blas ins
working on XM D so we've got a team
together they've got a lot of young
blood to because us old guys aren't as
good anymore at coding it seemed we can
talk a lot but we got solid Hamir we got
stefan craw is doing a great job on the
XD side but then tony and anthony honor
ood and david this is just the beginning
we'll need a much bigger team like this
we'll need at least you know you know
core group is a good core group
nor to accomplish our goals we'll need
hundreds of people to actually help us
get there once we define about the the
plan concisely and clearly we've got
some progress it's only about two months
old and we're going to show you some of
that progress basically right now we
turn over this to Saul
all right let's see here so I'm gonna be
going through this collab notebook and
it's also available on the youõre repo
so if you google viewer a should be will
follow along because there's some links
in here and and if you want to reference
it so we're gonna look at an example
it's a pretty simple example but it's
it's using the outer product operation
and numpy so to remind a little
refresher on the outer product is it
takes 2 nd arrays and then makes a new
one where the dimensionality is those
two dimensionality added together so and
you're multiplying basically the inside
so if we take two vectors here we see we
get this matrix out where you see the
elements are the the multiplication of
all the elements in these two arrays so
we're going to look at the operation of
taking the outer product and then
indexing so so we can try this out we
can say we take the outer product and
then we take the 5th row here and
something you might notice is that this
is actually pretty inefficient right now
because you're computing this full
matrix and then you're just taking one
row of it and you don't need to do that
right you just need to compute the part
that you are actually outputting which
is just one row yeah so there's some
wasted work and also it's tied to this
outer implementation where if you have a
back end it would need to know how to do
an outer product in order to compute
this result but really the outer product
is just a combination of some you know
smaller operations multiplication and
indexing so how can we take this and
improve it in some way so this is a
version that you know gives the same
result but it just manually goes through
and computes what you need just for that
one row so this is better because it's a
it's faster so here we have I did some
performance on my little laptop and we
see that this is the version that I just
wrote and then this is the original one
with a weird gap here but we see that we
have linear time instead of
and squared time so because we're just
computing the row we need not the full
matrix right so this is this is nice but
we did this manually is there a way we
can take the expression we had before
and give us something like this in an
automated fashion and something that now
depends on more primitive operations so
it's more easily translatable to a
different back-end so this is where
Lenore's work comes in we see that in
her work we thought we think about
arrays as having a shape and indexing
and this is actually how we in this
example I just showed this is how we're
we're writing this function right we say
what's the shape of the output and then
now that we know the shape what is the
values inside of the output array given
the index so it's a function from our
index to the data inside along with our
shape and that describes the array that
describes what it should be right so if
you have that description you can
generate this code or generate other
code that is semantically equivalent so
here I go through it basically taking
this notation is from the mathematics of
array but what we're doing here is we
start basically we look at our
operations we have indexing and we have
this outer product and we see how does
how do you get the shape of indexing
something right well that's what's the
resulting shape well it's it's just a
shape of the thing that you're indexing
you know taking away that the amount of
indexing you're doing so if you have a
three dimensional thing and you're
indexing it with two tuples your end up
with a 1d array so this describes that
relationship and without our product you
know if you're taking out a product of
two things the resulting shape is the
shape can cat it together and we can do
the same for indexing so we can see that
this is I think intuitive maybe to
people using Python but the if you're
indexing twice into an ende array it's
the same as if you put those two indices
in one index right so if you do one and
then then two it's the same as one comma
two all in one so this is like a rule
for if you have multiple indices how do
you turn that into one
expression and same for outer product if
you are indexing into an outer product
what what is the value inside well the
value is indexing into the left array
indexing the right array and then
multiplying them so these give us sort
of the semantic definitions for these
expressions and they're not really tied
to the numpy code they're tied to what
we mean when we say outer product or
indexing so we can take our expression
that we had and we can we can use these
rules and we just take this expression
which is indexing the outer product and
find out what its shape is using these
mathematical rules and we see that it is
what we computed it's the shape of B
here so I'll let you if you would like
to follow along you can find this source
and and I'm kind of following the syntax
here but we can do the same for indexing
we can say we have our you know our
we're indexing into this outer outer
product and we want to see what is the
result and here we get the result is a
index by five times B indexed by I and
if we go back to our code we see that
that's exactly what we coded here a
index by 5 and B index by I so all this
math was is a formalization of going
from this to this given what we know
about these operations so now that we
have some math theory behind this we can
automate that and so this is what you or
a can help with so you are a is about
taking these high-level descriptions in
Python turning it into some you know AB
more abstract representation and then
compiling that so that you can actually
use it alright so this is the way that
we can target multiple backends is
because we can say you have some way of
describing your computation we're going
to bring it into a form that's a more
abstract and then we can target that
towards different backends so here I'm
showing I'm going to start with sort of
the low-level way to do this in ura so
we're we're making two arrays here and
we're saying that they have no we don't
know what their contents are we're just
labeling it and we say they both have
dimensionality of one and and this is a
bit verbose but it's a weight
describing these input arrays and we're
describing them as a sequences with some
length and then some getitem function so
it's a recursive definition of an array
and so we can take these inputs and then
we can build up the expression that we
just wrote right we're taking the outer
product and then we're indexing and now
we have this expression but it's not you
know we haven't done anything we're just
expressing what we want to compute right
so then we can take that and apply our
reduction rules just like we did in the
math and we can get a simplified
expression here and so this simplified
expression has the right length here
it's B and then the the inner contents
it is a bit verbose but if you squint
you can see that we're getting the fifth
item of a and we're getting the item of
B so we can look at this a little bit
more we can say you know making sure
that the shape is right and so just
verifying it this works how we expect
verifying that when we index this that
we get what we said we wanted to get so
this is all fine and dandy but this is
pretty low level and no one's going to
write this if they're trying to solve
some problem so now we need to build
some user interfaces on top of this
right that translate from existing ways
that people interact with array
computing bring it into this form and
then bring it out again so one way we
can do that we started building a numpy
API compatible wrapper so you can wrap
your lazy expressions and then call the
numpy methods on them right and you
build up this array expression so you
can still use what you're familiar with
but then you end up with an abstract
representation of what you want to
compute that's great but now we actually
if we want to actually execute this we
need some way of turning this into code
or into something else that we can run
right so for that we just have a
preliminary function called optimize and
we can pass in the dimensionality of our
arguments and our function that we want
to process and we get back a new
function right and if we look at what
this new function what the source is
that's generated so this is pretty messy
and but it's it's equivalent to what we
had written above for the optimized or
more efficient version of this array
expression right so we're iterating
through the dimensions and then we're
multiplying and saving that result back
so that the important part isn't
necessarily that this result is is that
great or is going to save you a bunch of
computation right now the important part
is that to get here we first went to a
place where we're not talking about
numpy and we're not talking about its
interface we're talking about generic
operations on arrays and how those are
defined and then we went back and said
okay now that we have that let's turn
this into numpy code so that we can
execute it but you know the plan is to
take this and then turn that into a
lower-level code or other libraries as
well like you could translate this into
a tensor flow graph or what have you
right because it has the semantics
expression of what you want to compute
so the goals here we want this to be an
open extensible interface meaning that
we can't write the world we want to
provide the framework so that people can
write parts that they need and register
them for different backends so it should
be sort of an open core kind of model
where there's a place for you to put
what you want you want to express if
that's a new operation or a new back-end
that you want to target so that where
you know we're targeting numpy and kind
of Syfy API coverage as a good metric
for is it solving you know real problems
we're adding different code generation
backends and we want to make it you know
more sound so that you know what you're
writing is going to produce meaningful
array expressions that you're not just
generating garbage and there's a bunch
of very interesting problems you know
from UI design to how we compile these
things and that could you know have a
big impact because we can target all
these different backends so yeah I look
forward to talking with any of you about
problems that you think would be
interesting for this or different
techniques or ideas about how to make
this process work so thank you
well we wanted to leave a lot of room
for questions hopefully there's people
the audience I mean many people here may
not spend their time dealing with the
race but hopefully you have some
thoughts about the approach we're taking
and kind of the many questions sometimes
there's no way to figure out the shape
of it Rea like in boolean indexing you
could never find out to shape up the
output of the random so others well you
wouldn't be able to yeah I mean but you
could do parts of it I mean task itself
the reason exam is because it's a
delayed computation you can have that
same formalism described here you just
have a missing placeholder I don't know
the shape therefore I can make certain
assumptions but I can still translate to
lower level code to get sent information
later when I do get it then I can go
from there
it illustrates that the code were taught
we gave a very simple example here but
to really be useful in this space there
are a lot of complications there are a
lot of different places where you know
we're knocking it we're not we're
actually not talking about an attorney
compiling the world right we're not
talking about hey every single
expression you're in a riot will go down
to little overseen code that will be
possible in some cases the majority of
cases you'll have runtime libraries
it'll affect lis support and you'll be
going down to a computation interpret
interpreter on those runtime libraries
which is basically what Basque is doing
today using numpy as the interpreter or
combination of no fire bandits so we've
got X and D as a generic and X and E
really is a low-level library it has a
lot of the key features necessary to
implement anything with this broader
type system that's very broad type
system it allows for much more
complexity and currently exists in
nobody we had a question over there
think you can get this to a question
yeah I guess I've looked closely at that
because that was a possibility and if
tensorflow
were actually able to win I would just
do that but they they Basin fortunately
took a track like that you know we
already had problems numpy and they went
by pre numpy and decided a fork off of
the older version there's a lot of work
they have to do in order to get this
capability can it happen maybe maybe
what will happen as will actually
inspire them maybe will happen though
will actually just inspire them and then
they'll fix it right but something has
to be done and waiting for tenth floor
to do it's not the answer right so will
this become the next version of numpy
inside fight maybe maybe it'll just
simply inspire the next version which is
based on tensor fall yeah the other
thing I'd answer yeah what add is that
the composition is helpful if you want
to experiment with a back end so if
you're writing new hardware or whatever
and you want to plug that in more easily
then tensorflow is not as suited for
that kind of swap ability it's good for
if you're at Google building you know
that hardware and integrating it
vertically but it's not as distributed
if that makes sense at the different
layers it's not as easy to plug and pay
play different parts of it yeah yeah
a little bit more details I'd like it's
one of the best engineer
they have really good separation of
concerns
they can just swap creature groundswell
better house
they don't have a type they have a type
system it's very nascent it's anemic
actually their type system dynamic and
could that be improved maybe and maybe
we show them how and then they just
borrow from it they don't they're not
doing the mathematics of arrays also so
I see again this is a research project
to be clear this is not something you're
all going to import tomorrow or really
even next year if we're successful then
you might fall of 2019 all right we
might have something that you'd be able
to use but yeah go ahead
of knowing these dance moves value
don't
yeah I think they've seen parts for me
are that we're taking a very practically
used library like numb by the details of
how it's built tensorflow is kind of a
it's a fork of numpy but without the
richness of parts of numpy - right and
so it's got its got other features and
hope I didn't have doesn't have what
you're really valuable but it'd be great
if you're all working together that's
not happening maybe it could've happened
earlier but it isn't happening right now
there's different agendas but they're
not the only ones in town either we
talked about tensorflow but pipe torch
is also there and also a very big
community around it and so is it gonna
be tension floor pipe torch which one
maybe you should be both maybe maybe
both can collaborate together correct
there's a whole community of tablet
operations which people think of this
different but they're really not that
different right and so I think that's
you know I consider some of the pandas
community to be a fork as well right and
so I think we have a lot of forking
going on and not a lot of interfacing
going on so our approach to that is to
go to the Foundation's work with the
mathematician who's worked on this for
years and try to come up with what we
consider to be a strong foundation now
engineering wise what's that going to
translate to in terms of will you do
differential array programming on this
system next you know and then those in a
spring know by fall maybe and then maybe
I don't know what that's going to look
like right but you know twenty years ago
people thought I was stupid for doing
numpy sci-fi like I should have just
been using MATLAB or should has been
using whatever they were
I've never been one to take to not lead
out on something if I think it's the
right answer and it's always risky yeah
go ahead once you can find that Samantha
right I think that's the key piece we're
trying to figure out it's what does that
have had a subset that could then be a
foundation and maybe you know people
could use that either copy it directly
or depend on it or whatever they want to
do yeah that would be awesome wouldn't
it I don't know I'm not gonna comment on
that quick question are you having those
conversations it's or proxies anyway go
with oh yeah absolutely because seems
like they always have a model that
nobody knows about if you've seen with
public and so there they're working on
the next one anyway correct correct they
are and they're yeah we uh we talk to
people at Google all the time
I love war I've never talked to the lead
of Google the other Google is a big
place actually there's a lot of
different books and you don't
necessarily yet they themselves don't
know who's in charge sometimes and so
but you could go you talk we have a lot
of connections there but talking pretty
closely with the Facebook engineers
around five tours and know what they're
doing they're doing a lot of really
powerful things too so the challenge is
all they're like deep learning this cut
the imagination of the world but there's
more to a rate program in the deep
learning and what's happening is they're
doing this very narrow skyscraper
whereas the site Piper sis was much
broader and it's unclear are they gonna
support all that or they just can ignore
it are they gonna what's the story gonna
be I don't know
without any kind of action it's unclear
right you have this sort of isolated
site by community in the medieval
earning community and they really ought
to join and people are interested in
that but how do we do it this is one of
our answers this is sort of our approach
after looking at the problem for about
nine months
happy to get your feedback though like
the open source project we're just you
know people interested in solving hard
problems and doing them as well three
counties
they do yeah in fact I would love it if
we could share our geo math concept with
arrow for example that's so exiting is
separate from you from you are a for a
reason you raise about the interface
specification some of this could be
useful for Ella potentially I arrow is
gonna get its first implementation we
did some work with them this summer as
well to get GPU support you know from pi
g DF into arrow it's pretty nice it
computational curls an arrow it's kind
of sophisticated as the either and
either xnt or numpy and so but they like
it that way because they want to kind of
be able that it's the data structure is
pretty complicated they have a fairly
complicated data structure so I said
theoretically that it could be described
by X and D and I started love it to be
we haven't focused on that because it's
already a very rich ecosystem and you
don't know if you have to make changes
to our I think our type system and Exedy
is sufficient it could describe an arrow
container but it's work to do because
it's a fairly mestan structure
there's a lot of different data
structures though my thesis is there's
not there would never be one data
structure this is where I disagree with
the arrow people sometimes something if
you really gonna do they don't really
disagree but there is never one
Universal data structure there are lots
of data structures depending on
algorithms data structures depend on
what elevator your plane if you got some
algorithms one data structure to be
better for that algorithm then another
algorithm for data structure so data
structures there's lots of them now
there are some common data structures
that work well for a wide variety of
algorithms stranded pointers tabular and
you know arrows come up with a fairly
straightforward tabular approach that
seems to work for some kinds of
statistical operations but ribbits
processing is that their idea of
structure likely not know for a
differential array programming no
probably not either I mean so there's
not a single one that's my view so I'm
much more interested in systems allow
composable reuse of Algar that of
compute kernels on top of arbitrarily
described data structures for a long
time the world has been missing a data
declaration language we have confused
type with language so I can't share
that's why it one reason for the silos I
can't share my description of the data
structure in Java with the Python user
very easily so I have to serialize and
then I copy from one to the other even
though there's no reason I couldn't come
up with a data description that is
supported by both those languages so I
could just have a pointer and I know
what I know what it is in both languages
that's what egg Nilay vendee types does
is has a data description language that
every language can bind to so you know I
have data structure Kulas main in java
who cares for the Python program it's a
pointer to a datatype it knows about as
well it understands all the places where
the bits are and they can apply a
function and it has
to them that works with that kind of
data structure could you call it that's
what we're looking to do is build that
kind of for the X and D style and you
are a will be able to connect pretty
easily to that style as well that's what
I mean about the kind of weave nobody's
solving that problem really either ten
circle or torch they've kind of they're
going they are introducing different
kinds of flows but I understand why
they're pushing pretty hard in the
machine learning direction that their
concerns are different their concerns
are faster rate convey faster matrix
multiplies so it's a it's a very to rich
ecosystem but for a user it's actually
pretty confusing right now I think it's
actually really hard I look how to go
man I don't know what I tell somebody
because banks it's like hey I want to do
this so cool you're going to have to
learn for re objects I said it is one
that's kind of where we are right now
that's exactly where we've that's
exactly we want to go to I mean our
first implementations will be we'll be
using we don't compile the hardware
we'll compile to tensorflow right well
use tents are close to runtime I guess I
mean like if there's an existing
oh that's the key that you use the
algorithm to cut and kind of maybe
replace it from specific tensorflow
calls to you or a kind of a you or a
wrapper around the tetrapod so it makes
those that's our next step we hope to
have that within a couple of months
hopefully by spring next idea
now that's exactly the roadmap
these teams the same theory to describe
it we didn't get to the dimension
yes it's a rich there it's a rich theory
there's a lot but possible of directions
you know we're applying for a grant
actually if you're give this remember
who wants to give us a letter of support
for the NSF driver applying for please
let me know if you think this would help
your in your work in an industry we're
looking we need that we need the letters
of support from industry the NSF that's
important for them and their grant
writing application so if you're
interested let us know love to have your
support and help think Microsoft that
possibly man IBM now with redheads
acquisition we have some interest in
knowing what they're going to support it
as an offering 100% agreed there is yes
they all do they're all it's a challenge
of navigating of executive bureaucracies
they all want to know what to do and
they're all staring each other we can
talk more about that if you want if
you'd like but I'm looking for yeah you
might get a recommendation that bamas I
can crystallize what they knew they're
gonna be supporting with agree but I
would see the level of conversations at
the executive level you know coming you
know admin to the lower level you got
lots engineers who are cramming for a
number of different things
so but you know through open source
could help
I don't I think that's a different
problem maybe it could be related but I
see is a different problem but I maybe I
just don't see it very well
get dictionaries are raised to the same
thing right this is this wife this is
one of the problems with Java is it yes
theoretically they are but practically
they're not so yeah yeah but they have
you love them I mean yes you can think
of an array as a tree structure is that
useful to do I don't know I guess you
could implement one that way with this
with this mechanism and see for sparse
imitation I think it is for sparse
arrays it's actually a really fine
appreciation
[Applause]